what do you think the white house is
talking about in these trying times
price of gas matthew mcconaughey makes
powerful appeal for gun control at white
house cause this is something i care i
care so deeply about seeing celebrities
come out and talk about gun control when
gas is five bucks a gallon it's just oh
it's so smart good job it's brilliant
yeah
and the poverty that they're creating
will lead to more crime will lead to
more people
that's why they don't want to take the
guns exactly we all have armed guards so
it's actually not really matthew
mcconaughey's problem
so this is the next story
in an emotional appearance the white
house briefing uh room on tuesday
matthew mcconaughey matthew mcconaughey
made an emotional appeal for greater gun
control measures at once evoking anguish
and hope how he asked can we make the
loss of these lives matter oh so he's
outright saying he's exploiting the
tragedy for political it's nice of yahoo
to write uh this press release as a news
story yeah did you say in an emotional
appearance he made an emotional plea
[Music]
rather than logic he brought the shoes
of one of the children there and he also
brought a painting of one of the
children there that that lost their
lives uh this is also on the heels of
one of the teachers coming out and also
now uh during that incident talking
about another uh important aspect of the
story that again contradicts the police
official version uh there's so much to
this that that again is filled with just
emotions so you don't rationally think
about exactly what happened here but it
wasn't even a real emotion he was
looking at a script like for half the
the talk it wasn't like a i mean you
call it a speaker but it was basically a
cold reading of a script it was so
obnoxious and you were saying before we
started he wasn't even no he's like a tv
and film actor trying to do theater and
he's shuffling his feet looking all
nervous looking down like at least get
off book if you're gonna try and lie to
me make me think that you believe what
you're saying dude he said we this is a
quote we need to raise the minimum age
to purchase an ar-15 rifle two and then
he looks at his notes
21. like he doesn't even know what he's
talking about it's like the most basic
talking point i didn't even know what it
was
and meanwhile he's able to afford
private security he's able to afford
guys walking around with guns that are
going to protect him and he's making the
argument that of course no no you can't
have that no you're not responsible
enough flippantly said red flag laws
which would get like people with medical
marijuana licenses to get their doors
kicked in if they don't want to get
their gun over you know like come on man
what is he what is he thinking well i'm
pretty sure if you have medical
marijuana you can't get a gun you can't
not in maryland no no no no not anywhere
yeah what about people that have a gun
that get a medical mirror unless you're
hunter biden unless you're 100 and you
can do whatever you want that's
interesting that's fair if so um if you
guys know in the chat if you have
weapons already and then get a miracle
medical miracle medical marijuana card i
wonder what happens but you cannot
buy a gun
so
if you if you go to a gun store it asks
you do are you an illicit user of any of
any and it says in bold letters note
marijuana is illegal at the federal
level and you must well that's a problem
in itself they call it a narcotic at the
federal level it's considered isn't it
schedule one schedule one narcotic like
it's like a nerd i just i'm like no i'm
really boring i don't do any of these
things please give me my guess
the history of that marijuana being
illegal is insane to begin with harry j
anslinger colluding with uh what's the
the paper the paper industry randolph
yeah william randolph first and they
basically went and they did this this
propaganda piece called reefer madness
and scared a bunch of people and then
they made it illegal you know anything
that basically was the foundation of our
country yep i i don't care for smoking
weed or anything like that but it sounds
like gun control to me yeah because
you've got a lot of young people who
don't know or don't care you've got
people who walk down the boardwalk in
california and they're told just spend
five bucks and get a weed card and
they're all disqualifying themselves
from having guns that's insane that's
one way to do it right as they're
registered with the state and there's
there's been many instances especially
in colorado california where you hear
people denied the ability to defend
themselves because of going through this
process and you hear about the fbi not
actually being able to get through all
of their backlog of background checks
so i don't know well that's why we have
the 72 hour release and this is what
they still can't get through it well
right that but this doesn't matter
because after 72 hours it's gone right
and you get here you get you get your
gun joe biden's trying to get rid of
that and that would effectively ban all
guns all of them period how
so if right now the rule is
you have to get a background check when
you buy a gun from an ffl right
uh for the average person you get
researched and within five ten minutes
you're cleared right however sometimes
you get delayed if the fbi does not
complete the background check within 72
hours you get your gun right if that 72
hour release is removed as per joe
biden's you know demand then the fbi
will say we'll get to it when we get to
it and then you never get the gun
i mean that actually happened i so i got
my first gun in highland park new jersey
which is like one of the most liberal
townships yeah no it's bad it's bad they
banned fracking like this is how they
spend their time and the hoops that i
had to jump the illegal hoops i had to
jump through to get my my gun license
were
completely illegal there's nothing i
could do about it they just kept on
calling me into the back office are you
sure
are you sure and then they were sort of
misogynist and infantilizing because i
had my kids with me and they're like i
just are you concerned about your safety
are you concerned about the safety of
your children like i am concerned about
your ability to do your job in a timely
way and i would like the ability to
defend myself and my children because i
don't trust you sir you you police
officer you because you're not very good
at yourself i had the cops in new jersey
telling me to get a gun really yeah
some guy tried breaking in and the cop
was like i've heard me i answered the
door with a shotgun and i was like i
don't have one he's like well he might
want to go and i was like okay oh wow
and they they all lied to me as to how
to do it well the thing that kills me
about this story is that the lesson of
this texas shooting is that we should
never have guns
after we watched what the cops did
standing out there for an hour what was
an hour i'd i would rather have a gun to
protect myself and my children because
the mom who jumped the fence
she's the hero of the story and the
border patrol agent
borrowed the shotgun of his of his
barber he is the hero of the story and i
am not super interested in entrusting my
children and my safety in the hands of
those people and i'm i'm a back to blue
person and and i'm definitely not but
what happened
what happened in ivaldi is not rare it's
not uncommon this happens a lot this
happened throughout other school
shootings
parkland especially just one of them but
there's other events my friend joe
lozito dealt with this entire situation
as police officers were watching as he
was stopping a serial killer getting
stabbed in the head police officers are
have argued in many states and even on
the federal level they have no duty to
protect
this decision absolutely and it's
important for people to understand so
for them to use this emotional kind of
event in order to push for gun control
so people have to depend on the police
is absolutely insane disingenuous and
just
absolutely stupid and the only way they
could do it is is if they have enough
emotions and this is why we're seeing
such hyperbolic range and this is why
we're not seeing the mom who had to jump
the fence yeah and that mom right now is
being uh threatened according to her she
came out saying that she's threatened by
police yeah i'm not surprised for for
for speaking out against them yeah i
mean this is what happened in parkland
that it disappeared so fast once it
became clear what had happened and they
don't want to talk about it and so it
kind of it the story became the the hog
it was his name andrew david hogg thank
you the story became david hogg and all
these things instead of the dad who kind
of stood up and was like i'm sorry can
we have a conversation about what
happened with the police department yeah
the teacher came out today the the
teacher that was in the classroom where
he lost all of his students came out and
said he had to pretend that he was dead
for over an hour he heard police
officers and then he said that they
retreated they went away and when he
went away the shooter started again
hurting uh small children and this again
contradicts the official story of what
the police officers were telling us that
day so they were that they were outside
no they left they retreated they ran
away and then the the shooting actually
continued and escalated and more people
lost their lives when they didn't need
to and the cops are right there it's
disgusting it's absolutely insane yeah
no so i don't know if this panned out
this was like a sort of i heard it
originally when all this stuff happened
they were telling kids to yell out yup
that's one story as well and that
happened one of the teachers uh this
this teacher that came out today did an
interview at abc news and he said
specifically
how you know we heard the police
officers outside we thought they were
coming in we thought they were rescuing
and then they just left and then one
student said hey help me i'm here and
then the monster came in there and then
and then obviously you guys do you guys
see what david hogg tweeted about not
allowing not having immigrants come to
the united states like the weirdest gun
control talking point he was like
someone should tell
immigrants not to come to the united
states we should issue warnings in their
state their country should issue
warnings and i was just like
that's just like i don't know what his
point was trying to be but he went like
anti-immigrant
to argue for guns like
i don't know it was just where he goes
was he trying to art yeah right i just
think that we should just let him talk
all the time i i'm of the mind every
time he opens his mouth we should all
just listen and just learn
agreed i think so too if we ignore him
he's gonna and be little he's gonna get
more powerful so it really is someone
that we should communicate with well no
she's saying that the more he talks the
more he discredits himself i understand
but i also think that he's the kind of
person that if you make fun of him and
act like he's not a big deal will become
way more politically powerful than you
intend well look
when half of the political space in this
country is people who are willfully
ignorant and then accuse everyone else
of being willfully ignorant i don't know
how you solve for that problem anyway i
mean you see that in no more clear
context than with guns they do not
understand the very basic mechanics yeah
i'm thinking about policing because i'm
kind of with you luke that you can't
really rely on cops to save you but like
i think okay that we start from the
beginning again then you you have your
homeschooling your kids in your house
you have guns to protect it but that's
not scalable because you can't be on
guard all day that's why we develop
specialization as a species we have
people that
specialize in defense of the community
well no no no armed societies are polite
societies and and if you look at some
examples specifically when a criminal
knows that someone could defend
themselves they're not going to treat
them
like like a victim they're gonna know
that there's gonna be consequences if
they aggress against somebody else i
understand that but coordinated attacks
you can't no one dad is gonna be able to
stop i i am probably the only person on
my block
who has guns and i'm very okay with
everyone knowing it because at the end
of the day it's not my house getting
robbed
yeah luke i think your power cable might
be on your microphone or something yeah
i'm trying to troubleshoot it but i also
gotta switch cameras but but on that
note bethany there's this viral video
james o'keefe recently posted it where
they went door to door and asked people
if they were in favor of gun control and
when they said yes he was like
we have this sign saying proud gun free
home would you put that in your front
they're like no no like why not because
then people would rob us and he's like
sounds like you're saying you need a gun
to defend your home the funny thing is
these people who won't do it no they
don't need guns because everyone else
has them yeah and so i agree people
should be armed i think or at least have
the right to arm themselves and let
people know we're armed um but on top of
that you're still gonna need a community
police force at some level because
you can't expect parents to only to
always be on guard if you're teaching
your kid you're not on guard so at some
point you're gonna have to rely on your
community to protect you at some point
in in some instances um maybe it's just
gotten too big like having a small
police force i saw this chaos in
philadelphia the other night maybe two
days ago or something and there were
like four cops i think were there at
this huge crowd of like hundred kids 100
people out in the street just shooting
each other yeah well the crazy aspect is
you know the same kind of democratic
party establishment the same kind of
individuals that that are telling you
you can't have a gun you shouldn't have
a gun are the same individuals that are
usually financed and sponsored by
individuals like george soros that
literally are financing da's and public
prosecutors that let criminals leave and
get out of jail after committing very
horrible violent crimes there was a
crazy incident in los angeles recently
with a mother that was run over by by a
crazy criminal the the criminal got five
to seven months at a camp uh in response
to him running over a mother and her
child again there's been so many
instances of just horrible violent
people being let out into the streets
and these are the same people doing that
telling you you can't defend yourself
you can't have you know we need more
laws to go after law-abiding citizens
that of course won't be following uh the
the context and pretext that they want
them to thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there